now carl anthony's dad is coming over  here cracking jokes talking about the  jersey yeah that's what he wanted to  come tell us he's like oh that jersey's  going to fit a little wide  you got job then you got jobs down there  the ball is confirmed it is a clear path  foul  yeah  yeah now that they jar jar back and  forth you're right  walking towards call  town senior oh these two  they've they've been laughing and joking  all day  there's a minute to go in the game guys  it's like they knew you were just  telling the story i don't know  guys guys we got a minute to go  we can't  god this game goes  right we ain't nothing those folks  memphis memphis memphis  team maram  feels confident with the rest of the  series that is just great television  meanwhile it was a clear